back to school season is upon us but
we've got a list of games that you can
play instead of doing that homework here
are 10 of the biggest games releasing in
september 2022
you know that oof feeling you get when
playing a sequel and then returning to
the first in the series well you won't
have that feeling anymore when going
backwards in the last of us world the
last of us part 1 is the same game we've
all come to know and love but rebuilt
from the ground up for ps5 to help it
reach the bar set by part 2. it features
updated and improved ai a new
perma-death mode a speed run mode an
updated photo mode unlockable costumes
for joel and ellie and a model viewer on
the technical side part 1 can render in
native 4k at a targeted
fps or dynamic 4k at a targeted 60fps
display mode the added power of the ps5
means that the environments have denser
physics with tons of bumpables and
chippables that translate into gunfire
ripping concrete and other objects apart
more accurately with more than 60
accessibility options players can also
expect an audio description mode that
makes the title more approachable and if
ugly crying over the main story isn't
enough for you this also comes with the
left behind dlc you can pet those
giraffes all over again in 4k this time
when the last of us part 1 releases for
ps5 on september 2nd
in nba 2k 23 you control really tall
humans that throw an orange ball at a
bottomless basket attached to some glass
this year's edition of the game marks a
host of changes to the gameplay and
focuses on bringing balance back to the
offensive game new gesture combos such
as double throws and switchbacks are
meant to provide shooting windows in
tight quarters double throw gestures are
used for hop step layups while
switchback gestures are used for euro
step and cradle layups the game's ball
handling controls are also getting
expanded on with the full list of moving
crossovers nearly doubling from last
year's game from 15 to 28 options but
this year's changes aren't just about
offensive play on defense shot blocking
has been tuned to better reflect reality
you can add another game with michael
jordan on the cover to your shelf when
nba 2k23 drops for all consoles and pc
on september 9th
splatoon 3 is a colorful family-friendly
shooter that puts you in the shoes of a
squid kid to fight over turf this third
entry in the series introduces new
splat-fest that will feature not two but
three competing sides first teams will
take part in a standard turf war battle
but then they'll transfer to a special
tri-color turf war with all three teams
battling it out at once all of the
weapons from previous splatoon games
will be returning along with a new bow
and arrow-like weapon called a stinger
and a melee sword weapon with a charge
slash called the splatana the game also
features a new card collecting puzzle
game mode called table turf battle this
mode is described as a 1v1 battle where
you can fill slots on a board with cards
that show geometric shapes like tetris
pieces the co-op mode salmon run is
returning with a number of new
large-scale bosses and the game's new
story mode promises an epic finale to
the splatoon saga take part in the color
war when splatoon 3 comes to nintendo
switch on september 9th
jojo's bizarre adventure all-star battle
r is a 3d fighting game from cyber
connect 2 featuring over 30 characters
and spanning all arcs from the long
running series the game is a remaster of
the 2013 ps3 game by nearly the same
name it's just that this one adds an r
to that the game follows in the lineage
of past anime fighters such as dragon
ball z and naruto giving players a wide
arena in which to do battle while still
focusing on combos counters and waiting
for the right moment to strike in
addition to improved visuals new audio
recordings will also be used in game and
the fighting mechanics have been
adjusted including the addition of hit
stops and jump dashes the fight begins
on pc september 1st and console
september 2nd
steel rising is an action rpg that gives
a look at the french revolution through
an alternate steampunk lens in the game
you play as an automaton guard for marie
antoinette and you'll battle through an
array of mechanized enemies roaming the
streets of an alternate history paris
streets that are filled with secret
passageways and grapple points that make
exploration a joy take advantage of a
wide variety of weapons and skills in
order to define your own playstyle will
you be a deadly dancer a ruthless
warrior or a hard-hitting bodyguard the
choice is all yours but be ready for
steal rising's enemies to test your
patience and skill you can take back
paris from a tyrant king when steel
rising releases for ps5 xbox series xns
and pc on september 8th
metal hellsinger is a fast-paced
rhythm-based first-person shooter in
which you blast your way through demon
hordes to the beat of a badass metal
soundtrack it's everything you loved
about doom 2016 but unlike that game
timing your attacks with the music is
key to your success not only does
staying in sync help build a multiplier
and your score it also activates the
song's lyrics and makes the song more
intense the soundtrack includes songs
made specifically for the game and
features talents of matt heaphy of
trivium and serge tankian of system of a
down just to name a few and although he
won't be singing in the game you can
also expect to hear narration from the
one and only troy baker get ready to do
some karaoke in hell but not really when
metal health singer drops on september
15th for ps5 xbox series xns and pc
return to monkey island sees series
creator ron gilbert back to write and
direct and continues the stories of the
1990s adventure games the secret of
monkey island and monkey island 2
lechuck's revenge that means you should
be prepared to reunite with serious
protagonist guy brush threepwood in a
classic point-and-click-style game with
clever puzzles context-sensitive
interactions reactive dialogue trees and
bizarre swashbuckling situations you can
return to this island of monkeys when
the game drops on september 19th for
switch and pc
powerful creatures have invaded the holy
kingdom of kadus consuming and
corrupting their enemies mankind's only
hope are chimeras hybrid warriors made
of two joined souls in seoul says you
play as briar and luke two sisters that
have undergone the transformation and
have been sent on a mission to reclaim
the city from the wraiths the game
features a diverse combat system that
has you managing briar's superhuman
abilities as well as loot's ghostly
mythical powers simultaneously you can
explore the dark world of solstice this
september 20th on ps5 xbox series xns
and pc
serial cleaners the sequel to 2017
serial cleaner is a top down action
stealth adventure where you play as the
cleanup crew for the mob in 1999 new
york inspired by movies like reservoir
dogs pulp fiction and the usual suspects
you'll play through a non-linear story
covering up crime scenes without getting
caught there are four characters to swap
between each with their own set of
unique skills serial cleaners features
open world map design and you'll need to
use the environment to your advantage
but that shouldn't be too hard
considering you have what the game calls
cleaner sets a boost in awareness to
make better tactical decisions you'll be
mopping up blood and hiding bodies
virtually when serial cleaners comes to
every console and pc on september 22nd
the deal field chronicle is an all-new
tactics ip featuring several warring
nations and a mix of anime style 3d
models and more realistic environments
the game's world mixes fantasy medieval
and modern day influences to tell a
story that square enix has called
compellingly deep the gameplay includes
real-time tactical battles and strategy
based combat that utilizes small squads
you can learn if the blue fox
mercenaries are a symbol of hope or
tragedy when the dealfield chronicle
comes to pc and every console on
september 22nd
so which of these games are you most
interested in and are there any you
can't wait to play that didn't make the
list let me know in the comments you can
follow me on twitter at devante chisholm
and make sure you're subscribed to
gamespot for more
you